[Applause]
okay so
um khabib fights this weekend
okay he easily beats justin
gaichi which is supposed to be his
toughest fight yet supposed to be his
toughest bite yet
uh dominating fashion i saw it was wild
unbelievable
shout out to justin gaichy that dude is
just an amazing guy like he just seems
like so much fun he's like a
golden doodle like he just has this
great energy like he was
he literally said afterwards he was like
yeah getting choked out isn't that bad
you just have a nice little dream then
you wake up not that much damage like
he was dead for a second bro like done
yeah so um but like he's just got this
great attitude about it
khabib retires yeah 29-0 has i think
lost two total rounds in his career
never bled never bled that's so [ __ ]
crazy
in a sport where you can throw elbows
yeah and and keep this in mind also
never bled and his style is not like
stick and move
no he wrestles he's there's tons of skin
to skin content yeah he could get a
headbutt
he could get a random elbow never
[ __ ] bled not even like nicked your
nose like you ever like bump your nose
and you have a nosebleed
all the time
[Laughter]
and then that [ __ ] hits you right in
your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
in all seriousness the conversation
right now is is he the most dominant
fighter in ufc history and jon jones has
a claim to
the throne obviously because he defended
i think or there's been in like 15 title
whatever defenses and not only defenses
i think some i think he had to vacate
the belt and then come back but he still
came back and fought for the belt so
15 total right right um
khabib is four so those numbers are
dwarfed by jon jones
that being said khabib has been more
dominant
there's been like questionable matches
for jon jones
nothing has been even close with khabib
or habib or whatever
as pronounced um i think the more
interesting discussion is
is the lightweight division
more entertaining now without khabib
yeah was his dominance and reign
so superior that it started to become
uninteresting right like
it we were excited about this justin
gateshea fight we're like this guy is a
wrestling pedigree he was a division one
wrestler and he was getting some shots
off on khabib he got a couple shots and
justin gaichy hits hard
yeah and we just ate them says easy
light work
i think the division is actually more
exciting i think the ufc is more
exciting without khabib and there's no
knock on khabib
i mean he's absolutely amazing and put
him up there as the goat because he
dominated
in a way that jon jones didn't dominate
that being said we want some chance one
of the great things about mma is that
there's chance one guy could get clipped
and goes down
he was so dominant that he eliminated
chance
yeah i i'll be honest ufc makes more
money when conor mcgregor is
the champion and the fact that conor
mcgregor has a chance
to fight for the title next and i'm not
even the biggest connor fan per se
i just recognize his entertainment value
it's trump level entertainment right no
matter what he's involved in it's going
to be entertaining
sell your shitty whiskey entertaining as
[ __ ] yeah we don't care
the fact that he has a chance to fight
for it and he's fighting against guys he
can beat
he can beat uh symporia because he beat
him before right right he
the gate she fight would be really
interesting but i think he could beat
gaichi he could beat tony ferguson
there's a new guy michael chandler and i
don't know that much about him all i'm
saying is
mma just got more interesting how often
is it that your most dominant champion
leaves yeah and it gets even better
mayweather left boxing we haven't
watched a boxing match since
i asked somebody fury wilder was the
last fight we cared about outside of
fury while that's it
since floyd retired that's the only
boxing is [ __ ] a snooze fest
without floyd yeah and mma is exploding
and i actually think this is
the right thing for mma what are you
guys thoughts on this i
i don't know as much about the overall
division necessarily but this was my
first khabib fight and that was [ __ ]
i've never seen anything like that
boxing or mma just like the way he kept
coming in who was the guy that [ __ ]
hello
two or three times and uh triple g
triple g
yeah gennady golovkin yes and i remember
he would just eat punches from
kazakhstan
[ __ ] sasha baron this was like that
but even more so
khabib just ate every punch and then
just kept coming apparently fought with
three broke two broken toes and a broken
foot in his bones oh that was the other
thing yeah
and then his chokehold submission he did
as an act of mercy to to uh
gaze because he heard gait you would
never tap out and he's like well if i do
this arm bar or whatever i will break
his arm
so let me just put him to sleep and win
like he was because his parents were
watching
his parents were watching this i've
never seen anything like this i wish i
had watched all of his fights
now i'm like i'm sad he's retiring
because i'm like oh i would have watched
every [ __ ] fight you did from now on
yo but imagine like the fact that he's
this [ __ ]
dominant insane at ufc like he's going
to be the
best muslim like oh yeah dude next
level muslim the discipline oh my god
no the world needs to be afraid now
that's not saying if i'm khabib's wife
i'm like
he has no outlet oh but islam is the
outlet
he's going to have islam you're not
supposed to be fighting his forehead
from slamming his prayers down bro
throwing those rocks at satan just
whipping him as hard as
how can you be of like islamic and fight
i thought that's against the religion
not they have jihadis bro like that's
like part of the religion that like
well they could just kill [ __ ]
sometimes right not sometimes like
in an act of defense and i guess maybe
you could look at like hey this person
is attacking me
and therefore i can defend myself
against this person
you